[Musique]
après deux jours de discussions les
ministres des finances du g7 s'accordent
sur un impôt harmonisées pour les
grandes entreprises avec un taux minimum
mondial de 15%
le g7 est une honte en soi parce que
substituer aux versions unis un groupe
de sept pays qui décident entre ce que
les autres vont faire
et puis ensuite le pass ou g20 même le
passo je ne sais pas quoi
dans une multinationale elle fait des
profits en france elle décide de les
délocaliser dans un pays où elles ne
payent que 1 2 ou 3 % d'impôt société
est bien devra payer la différence à la
france cela pourrait rapporter à l'union
européenne 50 milliards d'euros dont 4,3
milliards pour la france
alors qui cela concernera le g7 évoque
les 100 multinationales les plus grandes
les plus rentables et assez peu pays qui
ont un taux 10 ans inférieure à 15%
il ya quelques cantons de suisse mais ça
reste 15 % par rapport à nos 28% déjà
avoir le au moins 15% nous a demandé des
jours et des nuits de négociations
donc il faut pas cacher que ce sera
difficile d'avoir plus de 15%
mais la france comme elle l'a fait
depuis quatre ans ne ménagera pas ses
efforts fêtez la main à la poche et
prenant l'habitude parce que dorénavant
on va vous en prendrez chaque fois un
peu plus pourquoi parce que la
civilisation humaine va devoir bifurquer
ce n'est pas un choix c'est une
obligation
elle va devoir bifurqué pour ça donc il
va falloir financer de gigantesques
transformation il est important que nous
ayons ce débat cartes sur table avec les
français on casserait de la manière
encore une fois je le dis là plus
apaisée possible on n'a pas le choix on
sera obligé de porter des réformes de
toute façon pour équilibrer les finances
publiques je veux dire qu'il faut
travailler progressivement plus
longtemps c'est pas forcément très
agréable à entendre
oui le sujet est sérieux oui il faut
penser à l'équilibré retraite eh oui
on devra prendre des mesures qui seront
peut-être impopulaire les décisions de
monsieur joe biden le président des
états unis d'amérique donne un point
d'appui à des gens comme moi
considérable dont on punit pas rêver il
ya encore deux ou trois ans quand il
décide d'un impôt mondial quand il
décide de de distribuer de l'argent
c'est quasiment l'argent hélicoptère et
notre frontière est grande ouverte
libération inégal montre en flèche un
niveau que nous n'avons jamais vu
auparavant et cela sur une période de
plusieurs mois
donc tout ça ce sont des choses que le
moment venu si j'en ai la responsabilité
je transpirais en france monsieur byden
signe la fin d'une époque
le pays dominants du capitalisme est en
train de tourner la page du néo libérale
sable le prix de l'essence en vol
nos industries sont pillées par les
cyber attaque étrangère
c'est un manque de respect pour notre
pays et nos dirigeants et faites moi
confiance sur les présidentielles
il y aura un candidat des républicains
parce que moi entre macron et le pen je
ne me retrouve pas eric zemmour fera ce
qu'il voudra fera ce qu'il pensera utile
et juste pour notre pays parce que je
pense que la seule question à se poser
dans ces cas là quand on a une telle
démarche c'est est-ce que ce que je fais
est utile pour mon pays
oui je mets les pieds dans le plat oui
je lis et je l'assumé je lis l'explosion
de la violence dans notre pays à
l'immigration incontrôlée évidemment
qu'il s'agit pas de généraliser et la
violence entre fr eric zemmour êtes un
éditorialiste et un écrivain respecté
écouté n'affaiblissait pas même un tant
soit peu n'affaiblissait pas le camp
national auquel je sais vous êtes
attaché pendant la période du
confinement je ne sais pas comment notre
pays aurait tenu sans ces milliers de
femmes et d'hommes qui sont immigrées ou
enfants d'immigrés qui ne sont pas de
nationalité française et à qui nous
devons une fière chandelle
ils ont fait un pas vers la république
pendant le confinement j'ai souhaité que
la république fasse un pas vers eux et
que nous puissions les naturalisés ils
sont aujourd'hui nos compatriotes et
j'en suis très fier